and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead jish
a civil engor turned data scientist who
decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish Chang gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get ahead isio nikara
simply learned from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time
transformation simply learn industry
expert data
exper with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that long
didn't choose a quick fix he just added
data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop Nan from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passion
situation
you too will find your way to get ahead
when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
recording in
progress so we have our crowd joining in
hello and welcome everyone to our
webinar today uh we've been joined by
the open open group team and uh we'll be
discussing the toap standard 10th
edition and toap certification
portfolio uh meanwhile the the audience
joins and I would love to know where you
guys are joining us from the chat is
open you can punch in your state the
city or the country you're joining us
from we would love to know where you are
joining us from
today uh my name is Akay bker I'll be
your host for today and I part of Simply
learn and I'm joining from Bangalore
India we have people from Toronto
London guram
India great we have an audience from
around the globe today Dhaka
Bangladesh
Mambi great great great
great before we begin I would like to
put some ground rules uh please I
request everybody to put your questions
in the Q&A box below uh uh please avoid
them putting in the chat box so that we
don't miss out on any of your questions
uh this yes this session is being
recorded so you'll be you'll expect a
followup email with the recording link
and the webinar certificate I would
request all of you to fill in the post
webinar survey once we leave the webinar
with all your details so that we can
send in your webinar recording along
with your certificates as
well uh before we begin I would like to
run a quick poll just to understand uh
the experience level of our audience
today uh uh the poll is live you can
punch in your responses you may be
currently studying 0 to three years of
experience or you may be three to five
or more than five years of
experience this is just to uh understand
our audience so that we can tailor our
session
accordingly I would request all our
participants to punch in their
responses
thank you all for the responses I will
keep the poll open for another 5 seconds
before I close
it thank you all uh as I can see
majority of our audience are already in
the workforce about 80% of our audience
has more than 5 years of experience few
of them are currently studying and the
rest belong to the other
categories me share the results for
everybody to
see great I would like to introduce our
uh hosts from the open group today uh
karuna and Andrew uh karuna over to you
take it over thank you AA thank you for
that just G to share my
screen
all right are you able to see my
screen yeah great so good morning good
afternoon good evening to everybody uh I
am karuna Krishna mes director of
membership and Market development here
at the open group I'm based in India so
I'm really excited to welcome you all
for today's engaging session so our
Focus as AA as mentioned is going to be
centering around um the toal standard
10th edition itself and we'll also 12
into the toab certification portfolio
which we have recently introduced as
part of the new standard now with me I
have my steam colleague Andrew O he's a
fellow and vice president of standards
and certification at the open group he
oversees all the certification and
testing programs while also managing the
standard process so all the
certification that you will be giving
henceforth is something that's been
designed and overseen by Andrew at the
open group right and I hope and trust
that you'll find this webinar enriching
and valuable please do not hesitate to
pose your question s um you you will
have time at the end of the session to
ask your questions if you have any right
and we would encourage you to uh keep
this session interactive and we'll try
and provide you as much as possible
information and insights about the
standard and the certification that we
have created right so uh today we will
be briefly looking at um the toab
standard 10 Edition what's changed and
then we'll also be talking about what is
the new certification portfolios looking
like what is that we have done now it's
it is something different than what we
have done for the previous editions so
the change that we have bought in for
the certification portfolio uh
additionally we will also be dwelling
into the new learning parts that have
been designed specifically for the
standard 10th edition now due to limited
time constraint our discussion of the
togf standard 10th edition will be
concise highlighting its most prominent
features only right um I'm assuming a
lot of you have already been introduced
to the idea of Enterprise architecture
and and some of you would already know
what toaf is right now toaf stands as a
permanent and and most um well-known
Enterprise architecture framework
globally and it provides a very
comprehensive methodology to design plan
Implement and govern an organization
architecture now it composes a
structured development approach uh
specific techniques a governance model
and a collection of guidance documents
now this widely adopted framework is
been freely utilized by staggering 80%
of the world's top 50 companies showing
relevance and Effectiveness it's also
noteworthy that the toap standard has
been continuously developed and
maintained by the open group since 1995
so it's been over 30 years that it's
been existed and we've been maintaining
it and also had different versions of it
now with the latest 10th edition and the
new certification portfolio launched
last year underlining its evolving
relevance and the adaptability to the
contempory times as well
right um now before introducing the
latest edition of of the toap standard
uh Edition we actively sought feedback
from the practitioner globally the aim
was to enhance and expand the guidance
provided right so consequently a major
uh alteration to this Edition is
implementation of an updated modelio
structure uh facilitating future content
extensions uh there is now a significant
emphasis on providing better guidance uh
which will be shown in the upcoming
slides so the 10th edition of toaf made
its debut in April 2022 bringing with it
a host of fresh features and
improvements a heightened focus on agile
environments and digital transformation
there's an expanded guid and documents
tailored to assist organization in
implementing the framework and tailoring
it to their specific business
requirements additionally this Edition
has introduced new learning Parts within
the toab certification portfolio
argumenting The Avenues for skill
development and certification so let's
begin you know examining the modular
structure of the toap standard 10th
edition so if you navigate to the open
Group website you will find a link on
the open group library located on the
top right corner of our website right so
once you click the library you'll be
able to see this top five boxes uh as
displayed on the slide now the first box
um contains togaf Library which contains
our Enterprise architecture related
content including the standard itself
right so here you will find not only the
standard but also supplementary
materials like the white paper guides
reference cards and more now unlike the
singular document format of the version
9.2 some of you who would be aware of
the previous versions now the new
standard has now evolved into a curated
set of documents organized into two
distinct sections so we'll talk about a
little more detail as we go along
right uh the first category is known as
the toga fundamental content now this is
the stable and long lasting primarily
corresponds to what was present in the
version 9.2 however now this has evolved
and been modular IED now the second
category which is highlighted in purple
is what we refer to the dynamic content
in the form of toab series guide uh what
you see in the fundamental content is
pretty much the watt of the standard
which is stable and enduring the second
um the toap series guide is intended for
you know what do we say how to of the
standard itself so adding a wealth of
new guidance and practical insights for
Effective utilization now this is as I
mentioned men um few minutes back that
this is the dynamic uh portion of the
content of the standard now we have
broken the entire standard into uh you
know multiple little circles to
emphasize on the modular structure now
this is what you will also see when you
get into the standard and start reading
it so on the left uh what you have is a
six toga fundamental content document
and then we have introduced uh 23 series
guides at this moment we expect this set
to grow over time right now the open
group Enterprise architecture Forum that
develops and maintains the toap standard
is working on additional content
additional series guides as well so we
expect this set of 23 to grow more with
an extended content coming along right
um I'll pause for a minute just for you
to just have a look at it know the the
different uh aspects that's been added
as part of the toaf series guide I will
be talking a little more detail as well
what the toab series guide consist in
the upcoming slides um as I pointed out
earlier the fundamental content which
has been um uh displayed here in the
green circle corresponds to um a stable
content which is actually the version
9.2 of the toaf standard so whatever
you've learned in toaf standard 9.2 is
what you will see in the fundamental
content and the editions are the ones
highlighted in purple which is the togaf
series sky right now throughout the 30
long year journey of toaf standard one
something that we have always kept is
you know continuity so that has played a
crucial role go in the development of
the toab standard now in the 10th
edition as well we have upheld the code
characteristics of the standard through
the toab fundamental content right so
when you're examining the fundamental
content uh you will observe that similar
elements from the previous version such
as the ADM it still present the
architecture development method right
that's still there you will see
cataloges diagrams matrices and models
of the um Enterprise segment and
capability partition among others you
know have been retained so this is not
completely different but you will see
similar content that you have seen in
the previous
Edition now what we have done with the
fundamental content is uh know it's
revised and reorganized the version 9.2
standard uh we have split it into
collection of interconnected documents
uh making it more adaptable for future
changes now this modularity enables us
to alter individual parts of the
standard as necessary supporting its
Evolution right so the role of toga
fundamental content is to provide
provide essential Concepts and establish
best practices that are stable and
enduring and the concepts in the toga
fundamental content are considered to be
Universal applicable to the toaf
framework uh the role of toaf series
guide is to build on the content
provided in the TOA fundamental content
by providing extended guidance for
specific topics concerned in use cases
right uh now as I mentioned the TOA
series guide provides the howto covering
a range R of topic now they cover range
of topics from General how to and
guidance on establishing Enterprise
architecture team uh to domain specific
material I'm going to go through some of
the toab series guide what's covered so
that you get an idea on what what what's
there in the new toap series guide right
um now the general how to includes the
ADM practitioners guide uh and the
guidance on the use of toap standard in
a digital Enterprise so you have three
documents uh pertaining to that um then
in terms of the business architecture uh
this which is again like the domain
specific there's a rich collection of
guidance on that and the most recent
document added is the business
capability planning right so this is
what you have and this has been
extensively done for this addition right
then we also do have uh three um series
guides for data information architecture
related Guides of which two of them were
added this year in
2023 um then we also have series guide
which gives guidance on security and
also agile methods so we have series
specifically for these dedicated um in
addition to that we do have a number of
reference models and Method guidance as
well as part of uh the new
standard uh we also do have a dedicated
guide to setting up an EA practice known
as a leaders guide this is something
spec very a dedicated series guide is
just talks about this so we have
something uh covered for this standard
right so that's what is the toab
standard 10th edition the fundamental
content and the toab series guide and
toab series guide is is expandable we
expect more series guides to be added as
in when we have more specific domain
related work comes in so that this is
going to be
evolving um now in terms of we have
compiled the collection of documents
into several formats for your
convenience so you can access the
standard in various formats by visiting
the open Group website it is free
aailable for anybody to download if you
want and we have also offering an online
digital Edition with a graphical front
end so if you see uh on the screen the
left side bottom corner uh just if you
can see this this is something new added
this this wasn't there for the previous
versions of the standard when they were
introduced but the toab standard 10th
edition has um a digital um version of
it uh and we also have additional
formats we have it in PDF that you can
download from our website as I mentioned
from our open Group group Library uh
there's also hard copies that can be
ordered from our authorized book
sellers uh now getting started with
standard right I know the standard
itself is extensive there are a lot of
documents so you might say you know is
it difficult to get started somebody
who's new to the standard right uh so we
have offered a white paper that serves
an excellent introduction to the
standard so even if you're new to the
standard this resource will provide you
with an understanding of how we have
structured it uh for those familiar with
the previous Edition the white paper
includes release notes detailing the
changes made so it's an excellent source
if you want to get understanding of the
standard without actually uh diving into
the actual standard document uh this uh
white paper also has recommendation how
to start using the standard right uh as
I mentioned the standard if I'm right is
about 1900 OD pages today but uh this
white paper is about 14 alter if you
want to have a quick review uh this
would be a good place to start with
right
um as I mentioned we have an online
digital Edition this is something
introduced for this time uh to make
easier to navigate to the expanded
content of the 29 documents right so it
provides you some assistance with
navigation and it provides a both
graphical entry so when you click on the
graphical entry it takes you the textual
edition of this standard right so if you
click on it and this is how the textual
um Edition will look like right um it
has links it has supporting information
um white paper and also pocket guides
links to downloads and also provides
this particular version also helps you
to give feedback about the standard um
what we have done in this u stand this
edition of the Tog standard 10th edition
is with the help of the digital Edition
that we have we have added a new feature
as I mentioned to provide feedback right
uh so uh there is uh this is an helpful
feature that wasn't there before so it
provides it gives you a option to give
feedback on any page as you go through
the standard and if you think there's
something has to be updated changed
right you can give feedback to us so if
you see on this page or on every page
you'll see on the top left corner a bug
sign highlighted on the red right so if
you click on it a form pops up something
like this and you can give your feedback
uh we have received several valuable
feedback since the standard has launched
in April 2022 and um the open group
Enterprise architecture Forum which
actually maintains the standard has been
reviewing the feedback and some of them
have been also Incorporated uh so we've
designed it to make it easier for the
practitioners right to provide feedback
on the standard so that the standard is
live and and the standard is relevant um
today as well right um as I mentioned
there there are pocket guide as well
this online pocket guide that you can
use this is again the condensed version
of the standard it has links to the
standard as well uh and the pocket guide
when you go through that right it also
has interactive search facilities so if
you want to if you if you already know
about Enterprise architecture and Toph
and some of the aspects that you would
want to know what's changed there's a
search option there so you can click on
the search button and then you know put
in your know whatever the search string
and be able to find the information from
this pocket guide
right okay so that's that's all about
the to standard 10th edition and how to
access it and some of the new aspects of
how you can uh get read the document and
the digital edition of it right so
that's stap standard now let's look at
the certification portfolio right now um
now the certification portfolio is
actually the training the learning and
the learning parts that we have built
around the standard so if you want to
become an Enterprise architect or become
a business architect or take any special
specialities this is the learning PA
that we have put together right um now
toap portfolio now covers both the toab
standard version 9.2 and the recently
introduced toab standard 10th edition uh
we often get to ask how often will we be
supporting the togf 9 certification and
to answer to that is that we will be
continuing to support it as long as
there a market demand and we see that
there's lot of market demand for the N
certification we know our some of our
members and and a lot of um the industry
out there actually are still on version
9.2 so we continue to support it so this
certification is still around it's still
valid it still be considered so you will
have support for it now we have
introduced uh the certification for the
toaf standard 10th edition some new
learning parts and if you are a toaf 9
certified then certain pathways on
getting certified for the new edition so
even that's something being introduced
as part of the toab certification
portfolio now uh given the extensive
range of content within the 10th edition
of this toap standard it seemed
impractical to establish a single
certification so this often prompts a
question on why there is no dedicated to
10 Foundation or AOG 10 certified as you
have seen in the previous editions right
now the rational behind this lies in the
abandoned and the diverse material
present our aim was to categorize this
extensive content uh into distinct body
of knowledge and learning paths each
addressing specific skill set and
competencies derived from the standard
uh we have identify these bodies of
knowledge uh which encompasses group of
information pertaining to particular
skill sets and competencies related to
specific topics now in the diagram um
progressing from the left to right we
have identified a body of knowledge as
ba for business architecture EA stands
for the Enterprise architecture
additionally we have outlined specified
body of knowledge um linked to novel
topics uh introduced in the 10th edition
such as you know aile uh specialist
digital specialist and EA leaders uh
this approach of uh of you know allows
us for a potential creation of future
body of knowledge corresponding to
learning paths as depicted on the right
side of the diagram so if you see the
one the Box on pil in purple it's it
says nothing it's just empty so the idea
is as more content gets added there is
going to be additional book of uh
knowledge that's going to be added and
that might result into a new
certification so it gives a scope for us
to add more certification right um so
which will be essentially again be
aligning with the toab standard 10th
edition and that's the idea behind
having this multiple certification for
the toab standard 10th
edition um now this is the current
portfolio before the changes for the
toab standard 10th edition right so some
of you are aware of the 9.2 version
right you would have seen some of this
would be S U familiar with the open
group open badges so the the top badges
shown are the certification badges which
is the toaf 9 foundation and the toaf 9
certified uh the tier drop which is
shown below um are the certification
based on the to standard U about it's
the smaller chunk which which we call as
the certification credential batches uh
these are smaller chunks of learning and
specific achievements right uh here uh
we have the new addition uh so we have
three certification so we have the toaf
business architecture Foundation then we
have toaf Enterprise architecture
foundation and then to Enterprise
architecture practitioner uh and we have
four credential
uh certification credentials so agile
specialist digital specialist applied
practitioner and leader we expect this
to grow as I mentioned over time right
this is what the to's uh standard
certification portfolio looks like today
and these are the certifications
available for all of you uh uh to uh uh
attend and
Achieve okay right now this is another
view of how what the certifications I
just thought probably I'll present it
before I know I hand it over to Andrew
right uh it's again a very high level
outlining of the toab certification
portfolio so you can see both the
certification based on TOA standard 9th
Edition which are in white if you see
these white two boxes these are the uh
TOA standard 9th Edition the new ones
are colored in blue here if you see
these right um and the italic elements
what you see is the italic Elements
which are presented in the blue are the
certification credential know the size
of learning modules as I mentioned has
been modelized into smaller sections
smaller chunk that can be completed in
shorter amount of time so in contrast to
you know doing a full multi-day
certification and that's why these are
uh they are called credentials not the
certification as such right
certification credentials is what
they're referred as the green with the
dotted lines are the boxes emphasizing
potential future editions today if you
ask us what they're going to be the
answer is no we don't know yet but then
as in when more content gets added as
part of the to G Series Guide we expect
corresponding to those we will be adding
new certification new certification
credential and that's why these that's
what represents the um the green with
the dotted line for the future
Edition so this is what the toaf uh
stand the certification portfolio are
I'll stop here and then I would like to
invite um my colleague Andrew who will
be taking us through the learning Parts
Andrew over to
you sharing would you want to go ahead
and sh your scen yeah I'll just as soon
as you stop sharing I will switch mine
on all right there you go yeah so let's
let's get the uh oops where's it gone
just take a second to get this going so
um just start the presentation
again okay hopefully you're seeing that
okay so thank you very much karuna for
for bringing us uh this far in the
presentation um I'm here now to talk
about the the learning path so that is
basically the different options that
there are for certification for learning
for training so it's and there are
different sizes of um of learning
available as karuna has mentioned what
we call the for the certifications which
tend to be multi-day activities versus
the smaller chunks of learning that we
call the certification credential so
let's get into that so first of all I
wanted to start just a quick refresher
of what we've got with the togf 9
program so if you're familiar with that
um you know you would study the version
9.2 standard
and if you come down so your option you
got two options as you come down after
doing your study you could take your
exam stepwise in which case you would go
to the left you would take the part one
exam followed by the part two exam to
get to what we call togf 9 certified
obviously the benefits of that is you
know you can take your time you can you
know sometimes it's easier to do
step-wise development rather than take a
a single long exam however if you are up
to taking the single long exam you can
take the right path there which is to
take what we call the togf 9 combined
part one and part two exam and that
leads just straight to togf 9 certified
so one thing there and it's just one
thing to be aware if you do go that path
you can only get to togf 9 certified so
if you if you happen to fail a part of
it that you know for example if you
passed the part one bit and you failed
the part two bit you wouldn't get
Foundation your your part one pass would
be held on file until you then add the
part two to it so just just to bear that
in mind that is one of the downsides of
doing the combined now if we look what
we've added in the Toof standard 10th
edition so on the right here as we come
down we'll start on the left side of the
togf standard 10th edition you'll see a
very familiar pattern so it's basically
the same setup uh for the Enterprise
architecture track so if you want to
become an Enterprise architect again the
choice is to do stepwise development to
take the part one get to foundation and
then later moving to practitioner if you
wish or you can come down again on the
right and take the combined now also
what you see here along the bottom so if
you look along the Bottom now you'll see
there is a a path from the toaf 9
program into the new Enterprise
architect program and that's what we
call the bridge path so if you are togf
9 certified so that's you know you've
you you've passed your two exams you've
got your high level qualification for
togf 9 you can take what we call the
togf enterprise architecture Bridge exam
to get across to become a toaf
Enterprise architecture practitioner
okay and then the other thing we've got
on the right there is TOA business
architecture now at this time we only
have the foundation so obviously you
just come straight down there's some you
know maybe in the future we will be able
to add a higher level you know
practitioner perhaps uh but at the
moment we haven't defined the body of
knowledge to sort of cover that
area let's move on to the next
one now adjusting that also we mentioned
that there are certification credentials
now and these can be taken from either
being um for what we call toga
foundation and up so you only need to be
toga Foundation qualified that could be
toaf 9 Foundation or it could be toaf
Enterprise architecture foundation and
these new learning paths are available
and we have an agile specialist a
digital specialist and also a toggaf
Enterprise architecture leader and I'll
talk about you know I'll I'll fill in
the details of what these are in the
upcoming
slides but let's first talk about the um
three certifications that we've added to
the portfolio as we mentioned
certifications are multi-day activities
you'll be typically looking at putting
in you know you know T typically two
days at each level you know two days for
foundation and then maybe two or three
days to add on to that for practitioner
depending on the precise sort of trainer
the open group doesn't actually
prescribe exact times the what the open
group prescribes is the the amount of
learning that has to be covered and
obviously that can differ between
different sort of ab abilities and
different trainers and different
approaches about how they deliver the
training so let's first look at the body
of knowledge for Enterprise
architecture as we started off if you
remember we showed you the full standard
which currently is 29 documents as we
mentioned if we were trying to cover
everything in in those 29 you know it
would be a very broad syllabus and
therefore it would be very shallow to
cover it all so what we've done instead
is to actually focus on you know parts
of the content specific to a you know
specific skill set or competency in this
case it's about being an Enterprise
architect what do you need to do you
know if you're actually creating an EA
you know these are the people for people
who are actually you know doing the work
so what we've done here is to um
identify a syllabus based on this set of
documents so it's the fundamental
content as you see in the green uh plus
six of the togf series guides now the
scissors there to actually show you it's
not all of a toggaf series guide and you
have to to go and sort of dive down into
the syllabus to understand exactly which
bits of learning are required from which
of the togf series
guides now these are the paths so I
mentioned earlier the top path there
that's coming in from the bridge togf 9
certified coming in from the bridge to
Enterprise architecture practitioner or
doing the foundation two you know the
two-step Foundation to practitioner uh
approach we also have what we call
photography a practitioner an applied
achievement badge and I'll cover that a
little bit later that's a little
something extra to to denote the applied
sort of level of learning that we wanted
to
impart so looking firstly at Foundation
what is it about um this is about people
you know and for people uh who need the
the basic fundamental con Concepts you
know the pro you know basic
understanding of what Isen methodology
the toaf EA methodology uh very suitable
for people who are working you know are
joining an organization that uses the
togra standard maybe working with other
people who who are EAS and not
necessarily an EA you don't necessarily
have to be an EA yourself to to still
get benefit from the foundation it gives
you the common language and if you look
at the syllabus there it's all about an
introduction to this an introduction to
the ADM an introduction to to EA and so
on so as I mentioned it's for people who
need a basic understanding people who
are working or joining an organization
applying the standard if we move up a
level uh to
practitioner so this goes beyond you
know the the basic knowledge but also is
about including the ability to analyze
and apply okay so this is designed for
people who are actually to be um
actively applying the toaf approach
people who actually creating developing
you know transforming domain
architectures people who are doing the
work uh people who are contributing you
know within actively within EA projects
we also think this will be valuable for
people who are working in agile
environments who need to understand and
apply EA in their work as well that's
one thing we've seen is that you know EA
can complement Agile development very
well as deed and sort of gives you that
extra bit of planning and sort of the
bigger picture often to to sort of set
guidelines and the approach for sort of
Agile
development this is the learning path
this is the Enterprise architecture
bridge for the learning path for people
who hold the togf 9 certific certified
qualification now what we tried to do
here was to actually recognize the you
know the learning the effort that people
had already put in to their um to their
EA development to their skills
development so in fact there's a
slightly smaller path um smaller exam
that you would take um instead of taking
a part one or and a part two which is
typically a 60 minutes and then 90
minutes for people who are going via the
bridge is actually just just a single
one hour a single it's a 60 Minute exam
so if we have time we may be able to
cover also what's in the the exam
details I mentioned there is a um an
applied practitioner badge now this is
something that's a mandatory part of
every accredited training course and um
and um what is it well this is actually
about taking an exercise as part of your
training course that's um what we call
experiential based learning so you basic
ly put in a
scenario and it's actually about an
organization that's undergoing a digital
transformation and then you're put in a
set of um sort of um positions there are
actually 18 different scenarios amongst
this story that you work through and
you're asked what would the um given a
certain situation what would the
Enterprise architect do next sort of
thing and that's based on one of the
togf series guides in particular and the
idea is you would do 10 of those
exercises um you would probably do them
in a group in your group that's
undergoing training and you would work
with your trainer it's not not designed
as an exam or anything but it's designed
for you know to to sort of um exercise
your critical and an analytical thinking
about how you would solve a problem you
know given the position that um that the
EA has presented and following one of
the toaf series
guides and that actually leads to an
achievement badge
now this is the body of knowledge for
business architecture so you you look at
this you say ah okay I can see that some
of that is common with EA and that's
that's true there is a certain amount of
commonality uh with the Enterprise
architect if you imagine the Enterprise
architect obviously goes around the
whole of the ADM so you know the full
cycle of the ADM whereas the business
architect is really focusing on the
first sort of quadrant going around you
know prelim preliminary phase a to phase
B so here we're looking at a lot of
techniques so you see there's the
fundamental content and then there these
togaf series guides you see there are
actually six business architecture
related togaf series guides there which
actually you know very um they're
focused on techniques uh such as
business modeling how you do business
capability cap business capability
mapping value streams organization
mapping information mapper very useful
techniques these are that you can take
back um to your organization immediately
after doing business architecture
Foundation and start applying now there
are two paths uh that you can get to
business architecture Foundation
obviously there's the one that you're
you're coming at the bottom here is new
and you're fresh so you've never done
any any of our business architecture
qualifications before you take the
business architecture Foundation exam to
Foundation now the Top Line there is to
recognize a previous certification
credential that we had which was to what
we called toaf business architecture
level one now that was based on the 9.2
standard but a lot of the tech
techniques are common between what what
we had documented in 9.2 and what's
available in the 10th edition so there
is a migration path so if you've done
that certification credential you can
actually basically uplift your learning
by taking an additional four modules and
then you can also get to business
architecture Foundation that
way uh what is business architecture
Foundation again it's about the B the
fundamental concepts getting the basic
understanding the the difference I would
say here is that there are a you know
some well documented techniques that you
can U you can study and you can learn
and you can take back immediately so
it's very practical it's for people who
want to apply the business architecture
approach um within their
organizations so you can come away from
this course and you can yeah I think
there are about 30 different exercises
we have within the course and you can be
applying you know a good at least you
know I think there's about six different
techniques you can start applying within
your organization to build out your
business business
architecture let's look now at the
certification credentials the three
credentials we added to the
portfolio as we mentioned credentials
are really focused on on being a smaller
chunk of learning so we're really
typically thinking about um you know
three hours upwards these ones may may
extend to a whole day perhaps um
depending on how much time you want to
spend but I I think you know they're
really sort of things that you can
self-study and take easily sort of
within a day
um first of all look at these the
digital
specialist this is about using the you
and applying the toggaf standard for
digital transformation in a digital
Enterprise and there's a specific um
togaf series guide that gives you a what
we call a transformation Readiness
assessment technique you can tell
whether your organization is ready to
undergo a digital um transformation you
can look at you know there's very you
can measure the sort of uh maturity of
your organization whether it's ready uh
as we mentioned earlier there is a
prerequisite so it's toga Foundation or
above these are the benefits so the
benefits would be coming away with an
understanding of how how EA can be used
to support you know a digital Enterprise
and also a load of techniques and best
practices for for digital technology
adoption agile Specialists a similar
approach as we took for digital
specialist um there are two specific
toggaf series guides that are focused on
and Agility so how you adapt the togga
standard to support you know Enterprises
that are you know have adopted the agile
approach also how you can use the
tograph
ADM in a sprinting model in an agile
sprinting model so if you're into agile
you're aware of agile Sprints we've
actually got a lot of advice from the
experience of the open groups
architecture Forum members about
applying that and again it's toga
Foundation or above as a
prerequisite benefits so it's
understanding agility why it's important
you know how you can use that with EA
how you know how an EA can be developed
in an agile way you know various
techniques iteration different iteration
cycles and so on for supporting agile um
again I mentioned sprinting so that's an
understanding of how you use sprinting
also some knowledge of techniques for
agile product management we've got
covered in one of in the Tog of series
guides lastly but not least is the what
we call the toaf enterprise architecture
leader uh certification
credential now this was something new
there is actually a dedicated togf
series guide uh just on establishing
your EA capability this is what we call
the toaf leaders guide obviously with
the toaf 9 standard we had sort of
touched on this obviously in the
preliminary phase and I think a little
bit in in the sort of the governance
aspects but now we've actually got a
full uh togra series guide I think it's
about 130 pages 15 13 to 15 chapters if
I recall that are dedicated for how you
set your organization up how you
establish an EA capability uh again
there is a prerequisite if you wanted to
take this credential which is toga
Foundation or above you will come away
with understanding you know what are the
key Concepts I need to know if I'm going
to be an EA leader you know the person
who's in charge of establishing the
capability you
know how you know how how would I
actually set up and realize a practice
how do I do that in my organization you
know what are the purpose what are the
you know what sort of purpose am I
looking for what are the objectives how
can I shape my organization there are
various different shapes that you can
put your um your EA organization into to
do its work depending on you know the
sort of the capabilities the environment
of of the organization you know how do I
put my governance framework together
what about you know AR architecture
contents Frameworks and so on and what
is my process model and so on what is
the how do I do the governance how do I
organize my roles and responsibilities
so there's a lot C C there that dives
into you know detail that we didn't have
before but has now been shared by um our
experienced members of the open groups
architecture Forum who've put this togf
series to guide together so that's
really what we wanted to cover today um
how are we doing for time I don't know
whether I should carry on to a couple
more slides just to cover some of the
resources that we've
got um yeah I think if it's going to be
taking two three minutes Andrew you can
yeah let me just carry on before always
cut a Q&A I've just got a couple of
resources to just share you know there's
a lot of information out there on on the
new um edition of the togf standard we
have a a YouTube channel so just very
quickly you can go to our YouTube
channel you can um basically watch
videos in different sizes here so you
could spend an hour watching something
or five minutes there are sort of
different chunks of a video that covers
it we have online self-study so if you
you know if that's what you prefer you
prefer to do self study in your time
we've got a set of materials that are
available that you can go we have online
practice tests and we also have some
study guides so that's really what I
wanted to cover today so I think I
should stop so we could uh take some Q&A
I
think thank you Andrew aay over to
you sure thank you karuna and thank you
Andrew for this insightful session uh I
think most of our questions were already
answered during the session
still if we have some left uh we have
one question in the que box toaf and TMF
how different are
they well
TMF if that's the Telly management forum
and they're really from the um focused
on um a particular vertical is my
understanding now I'm not the world's
expert on the teley management Forum but
um obviously they're really they came
from the Telco world telecoms and so
they're really focused on what it means
for the um you know the Telos out there
the you know the service providers
that's their focus um in my mind you
know the Toof standard is much more
General it's been applied across many
many different Industries um many
verticals different you know it's
designed as to be a much more General uh
framework a lot of it is common sense
that's what I always think um I've been
doing some Pro projects myself and and
you just sort of like it is a great
place to start you know my own personal
experience of using the TOA standard is
like um how am I going to do this well
then I can just look in the book and I
can pick up oh that's good advice and
you know it's sort of it's a great place
to start um as I say I don't know too
much about TMF so that's really all I
can say there interestingly in our
library there is one document which has
been archived which talks about toaf and
TMF uh maybe you might want to just
check our library I would say yeah
that's a little bit old now but yeah
that that is yeah
I can see some questions have come in
should we start at the top there and and
answer those can we upgrade from ba to
EA practitioner well they're parallel
tracks really so the idea is you can you
could do ba Foundation but you would
still need to do e EA Foundation to get
to EA practitioner unless you're coming
from Toph 9 certified in which case you
can
bridge that makes sense what is the
realistic difference between toaf 10 and
PMP well firstly there isn't a togf 10
there's what we call the Tog standard
10th edition and obviously our
certifications are very a skill set and
competency base so that's you know um
PMP again not something I'm particularly
familiar with but my understanding is
that is all about project management now
there are aspects of the TOA standard
10th edition I believe we do have um one
of the TOA series guides does go into
some of this I'm a little bit Rusty on
some of it it but um I need to look but
um again I think you know there again I
think for my mind the PMP is is very
specific to a particular approach um but
I don't know too much about it so
probably not the best person to ask
about that one uh another question says
do does toaf require any specific
technical skills like coding Etc and I
think the answer to that is no so
there's no sort of like you don't need
to be a c programmer or a shell
programmer or a or whatever you know
programmer
um do we need to do 9.2 first and then
10 or can we go to the Tog of 10
certifications directly and how many
exams are there okay um as I as we
showed hopefully on the learning paths
you have a choice um and for some people
they think yeah I've still got to do
togf 9 because I've got my employee my
employers are asking for for it or
there's a lot of job prospects where I
am in the market so I will do my togf 9
certification and then I will bridge and
then I will take the bridge which is as
I mentioned is a lighter path so it's
designed to recognize the effort you put
in for your togf 9 you can Bridge across
to togf Enterprise architecture
practitioner obviously how many exams
you want to take is really down to you
you know some people uh I see coming in
they've got their togf 9 certification
and they just say well right now that's
good enough for me but I'm interested in
doing one of the certification
credentials so we've had a few people
taking the leader you know that's give
them a particular benefit uh other
people they you could do them all you
know you could potentially do two exams
to get to togaf vaa practitioner one
exam to get to ba foundation and then we
actually have assessments which are a
little bit lighter they're an online
thing as part of the online self-study
for doing those certification
credentials so you could end up
potentially taking six exams just on the
new togga standard 10th edition based
bodies of
knowledge okay I am PMP certified should
I go for tograph well I think really
that depends about where you're working
and what you need for your you know for
for your job prospects uh one thing you
can do if you do get if you do get to
your TOA certification um you can go up
and you get one of our open badges as
you go through to our badge provider
they have actually a um a job skills
sort of um thing that you can click at
the bottom of the um of the badges page
and find out all the opportunities are
available for you so you you can also
just go up there and just see whether or
not you know if the opportunities for an
EA qualification look good maybe you
know maybe that would incentivize you to
to do
that what kind of assistance oh hang on
a minute what's the top one clear on the
togf 10 is there a dedicated Mac to real
as well as or do we need to go through
the Toof series
guides um not quite sure I understand
the question it may be related to study
guides and at the moment what we have is
we have a study guide for um for EA
foundation and we have a study guide for
BA Foundation EA and ba we don't have a
an EA practitioner study guide what we
have is online self study um and and um
really that's because of some of the
prac iCal elements now we haven't
actually felt the need to actually go
forward with a a practitioner self
practitioner self study study guide we
actually prefer people to to try and
take it online they get a bit more out
of
it um what kind of assistance is toaf
giving to company administrative or
technical um it's a very general it's a
very general method and you can almost
adopt pieces of it or all of it or you
know it really depends on on what the
organization needs you can almost apply
the toaf approach to um to almost any
problem it's it's a you know it's it's a
lot of it is common sense it's like okay
I've got a problem okay well what are
the guidelines what are the what we call
the principles you know that I should
apply to solving this problem that might
be what you would do first and then you
might say well how's that going to
impact the business and then it's then
eventually get round you can go the full
cycle you know is is that just a
business problem or is it going to lead
to a you know some sort of solution so
basically the ADM cycle you can go
around as much or all of it or down at a
very shallow or a very deep level um
it's really about um you know giving
giving people some a guidance a method
um as I say it's pretty much applying
common sense in many
cases um ba Foundation uh somebody some
So ba Foundation study material is
available available in the library yes
you can even get the hard copy uh um I
don't know if I've got a hard copy next
to me no maybe not study material you
know you can actually look at our the
open group shop that's where you can get
it and these are P you can't really see
the books but there are study guides
available you see on the library is uh
going to be the series guides because as
I mentioned when I was presenting that
each of these certification pertain to
certain um specific series guides so
they're bundled together and then the
certification has been created for it so
if you looking at ba Foundation there
are certain series guide which are
dedicated that you need to study for the
business um architecture foundation so
you can get that so you can go to the
whole certification but when it comes to
self-study material then you'll have to
take it from you know either one of the
training provider like simply learn and
then of course you also can check at our
study material available at the open
group shop I've pasted the link there
yeah there's a question here is there a
training path for credentials and what
the fees is is there an exam for it
really are credentials at the the moment
a a self- study um maybe over time some
of our trainers will also offer them but
you can basically go to the open group
shop which is shop. group.org and if you
have a look there you get all you can
see what's available and basically what
you can do is you can
um uh self-study we have what we call
the open groups LMS learning management
system you can go in there and you can
take I think we give you 60 days to sort
of go through an online course it's
typically typically their um the
credentials I think are eight or nine
modules so they're typically somewhere
less than about about 200 slides that
you would go through so it's it's quite
achievable you know in a reasonable
amount of time as I say they're designed
basically for they've got to be at least
half a day and up and I think these are
um currently um currently about one day
and then there's an assessment at the
end of
them which you take online so you can do
all of that within the learning
management system there was a question
here is can you please provide the
practice exams for EA and practitioner
again if you go to the um if you go to
shop. openen group.org uh you can find
practice exams there and you can either
buy when you buy them um you can either
get it gives you a pdf version it also
gives you credentials if you want to
take the same test online so you have a
choice you know you can when you
download it you get the PDF or you can
take it online Some people prefer to
practice online but the actual the
actual exam the practice exam is the
same at the moment we haven't sort of
broaden out too
many um can you reference book for
setting up EA verticals from scratch
um that sounds like good feedback for
the architecture Forum if there is a
specific specific EA vertical um some of
the Toof series guides obviously do give
you specific advice for example the
information architecture ones go down
into very sort of uh specific details
about particular problems metata
management and so on uh the question
here says are the exams relying on
recalling the material with multiple
choice questions or can we expect any
practical worksheet based
questions uh well again you need to look
at the exam plans and in there you will
see the part one exam is basically
simple multiple choice the part two exam
is something that we call um scenario
based gradient SC to read Theory and
there four possible answers there's the
best answer and then second best third
best wrong answer you've got to pick the
you get more points for the better the
answer is for our learning studies I
mentioned that is experiential based
learning that is not an exam itself but
it's part of an accredited training
course and you basically work through
that with your tutor uh going round
stories similar to scenario based uh the
scenario based exam except it's not
intend Ed as an exam it's it's more of a
learning experience but it should your
trainer then pass you for that they
submit your names to the open group and
then after you've got your certification
badge we will automatically issue them
with an extra applied badge to show that
you've done the you've completed the
applied um practical exercises I'll
answer this one question is there a
training path for credential and what's
the fee for it if there's an exam for it
so there is training pathway credential
in the sense that you need you need to
have either to give 9.2 Foundation
autograph EA Foundation as a
prerequisite to do the credentials in
terms of the fee I think it's available
um I'll share the link and then of
course simply learn also can will be
able to provide that information to
you uh then what's the next question can
you please provide practice exam for EA
Foundation it's already available if you
look at the study material uh as part of
that there are practice exam that you
can attend uh so I'll share the link
here yeah there's one question that says
if I self-study who do I contact to be
able to write the exams well again what
you do is you go to the open groups
website you go along the top and you'll
click on certifications and basically on
the pull down there is a taken exam and
it'll give you all the information you
need and actually take you to where you
can book an exam which is actually you
have to log in through the open group
systems and then it connects you to our
exam provider which is pearon View and
then you can book an
exam
so AA do you have present probably we
can take the questions uh yeah sure so
uh to answer to most of the questions uh
if there any provider who can help us
with the Topham or training course so
simply learn presents the to Enterprise
architect training course the foundation
and the practitioner course which
comprises of a comprehensive curriculum
with an industry aligned learning path
we have live instructor L sessions by
authorized trainers and it includes 18
learning studies based on the pr
standard 10th
edition uh the skills covered as we
already discussed during the session
today by and and karuna the skills The
Core Concepts of Toph 10th edition we
also cover the details of architecture
governance adapting to ADM architecture
uh the architecture maturity models and
architecture skills framework and all
the points we discussed today as well in
the end of it all you will be certified
by simp learn and accredited by the
open uh so if anybody is interested to
take up the course uh I will quickly run
a poll and you can punch in your
responses uh if you interested to take
up the Toph Enterprise architecture
training course I would uh would like to
see your responses in the poll which is
been presented on the screen uh if if
you're really interested please punch in
a yes and our team will get back to you
and help you with your further
enrollment steps as
well I'll keep the poll open for another
10 seconds so that all our participants
can post their
responses I have already also posted the
link in the chat box to our course page
link uh you can visit the course page
and view it in more detail and enroll
for
yourselves I end the poll now thank you
all for your
responses uh another poll coming your
way uh how soon do you plan to enroll
for this program uh we also have an
upcoming cohort coming up in the month
of January uh so if you're really
interested you can enroll right away and
be part of the
cohort uh if you're planning to do it
immediately you can punch it immediately
within three months within 6 months or
more than six months down the line so we
would love to know what our audience
thinks today so that we have a better
idea I would request all our
participants to punch in their
responses keep the poll open for another
10 seconds so that all our participants
are able to
vote thank you all for your
responses coming to the questions if you
have any questions remaining K do we
have any unanswered questions uh we are
trying to answer some of them one by one
just looking
again but just to uh mention again the
course link is already in the chat box
so if anybody's interested can visit our
website and enroll themselves for the
toaf
course I think we have answered most of
our questions
today so I would like to thank all our
participants uh for joining us for our
webinar today uh thanks to Andrew and
karuna for taking us to this insightful
session one last goal before we end uh
if anybody needs any kind of assistance
in enrollment of the course uh please
punch in a yes and
uh so that we can once you punch in a
yes our team will get in touch with you
and we help you with the further
enrollment steps I would request all our
participants to punch in their
responses
thank you for that
message thank you all for the responses
again I would like to thank karuna and
Andrew for taking the time and spending
with our Learners today so that they
have a better idea on how to go forward
with theph learnings thank you for being
with
us thank you Kara and Andrew and the
entire team of open group for joining us
today it was a pleasure having you guys
thank you a thank you everybody yes
thanks for letting us join and good luck
everybody and uh obviously we'll uh
there are any questions that we haven't
answered we can try and provide some
answers
later thank you all for joining us today
uh it was a pleasure hosting you all uh
if you have any further questions or
regarding enrollment or any other
queries please feel free to ask uh email
us at ask USS simply learn.net and our
team will be team will get back to you
with the prompt response as soon as
possible thank you all for joining us
today uh have a great day thank
you thank you
bye